hey let me ask you a question this is
what's been bugging me I'm terrible at
tech my son has been making fun of me
for years I can never figure stuff out
and now that we're all on our own we got
to figure this stuff out are you good at
tech now absolutely you know I can't do
anything this just like I've been
facetiming my my buddy Loughran who sues
helps me out literally everything I
didn't know how to turn on my so many
things in my house I don't know how to
well whatever it's humiliating oh I can
do the UH if the electricity goes down I
can find the circuit and flip it on and
off and when it works I'm just like I
handle that one that's that that's when
I'm most excited it's the smallest thing
and you feel like MacGyver right yeah I
changed the battery on my mouse the
other day or on my computer thing and I
opened it up put a couple of double a's
in there and it work that is not the
voice of a tech guy but you think my
wife knows my wife always knows
everything and how everything works
she's a good cook she everything is and
I'm always saying stuff like where do
they put the sink and she said woody you
an idiot it's right there in front of
you and I'd be like how am I supposed to
know I'm a genius you know I'm the
creator I can't know where the sink is
it's ridiculous someone told me that
you're wearing t-shirts that you get
from restaurants I don't even know what
that means what does that mean when I go
to a restaurant a lot of times when I'm
leaving they say hey Adam you want a
t-shirt and I say yeah sure you know and
I say say what sighs and I say double X
and they go no and I go well yeah and
then they go really to show them that
it's not that loose and it's a little
loose but right Wow better view Adam I
say I know but I need a minute may I
stop you for a second you say that when
you go to restaurants this is long
before the coronavirus but just as a
matter of habit and a matter of course
they give you free t-shirts at the very
the meal a because I'm nice I'm nice to
people I and we live in the same
neighborhood I've never gotten a t-shirt
they don't give me t-shirts well that's
an extra extra long on you man that
doesn't make sense you can't wear a
t-shirt are you extra long waste ahead
or no no I'm sorry wrong in the leg you
got long legs what Arbit yeah oh they're
crazy legs I got like 39 inch legs you
know I have super long legs and then I
have a tiny torso I have the chest of a
of an eight year old girl
yeah massive long legs yeah and I got
it's just I'm so I'm just proportionate
you know you like when you're laying in
bed are your legs kicking around you
don't even know it you go oh you you
feel your legs right yeah I can feel my
legs Adam yes I can feel my legs
yeah yes sometimes I'm fast asleep but
my legs get up early and they're like
hey he's still asleep hey right he's
still asleep yeah left let's get cooking
and then they start doing all kinds of
stuff yeah sometimes I wake up and I'm
just running 18 miles an hour down the
street yeah I'm in a Samba class it's
craziness